This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I love podcasts. I really do. Not just mine and the ones I'm associated with, but I listen to dozens of podcasts a week, and I'm always looking for some spark that excites me, comforts me, challenges me, entertains me. I love seeing the proliferation of podcasts. It would never occurred to me to mock it. Like, I know the joke. Everyone has podcasts now. But I always want more. You know, not all of them are for me. But when one hits, I just get excited about its existence. I get excited about
这里是“百分之九十九隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我喜欢播客。我是真的喜欢。不仅是我自己的和与我相关的那些，我每周还要听几十个播客，我总是在寻找能让我兴奋、让我慰藉、让我挑战、让我娱乐的火花。我很高兴看到播客如雨后春笋般涌现。我从来没想过要去嘲笑它。就像我懂那个笑话一样。现在每个人都有播客了。但我总是想要更多。你知道，并非所有播客都适合我。但当某个播客惊艳到我时，我就会为它的存在而兴奋。我会为
existence in general. And this happened to me when I was listening to a new show called California Love. It's a podcast about seeking to understand what it means to belong and not belong to the places that we are from. And the episode I thought would most resonate with you, my beautiful nerds, is about graffiti, which is a huge part of the visual expression of cities. There is a culture war being played out before our eyes in the back and forth between tigers and anti-tackers. And this kind of humane story is about those sides and what it feels like to be in the middle of it, where the stakes to an outsider can seem so low, but actually couldn't be
存在本身而兴奋。当我听到一个名为《加州之爱》的新节目时，这种感觉油然而生。这是一个关于试图理解归属感以及不属于我们故乡意味着什么的播客。我觉得能与你们这些我可爱的书呆子们产生最大共鸣的一集是关于涂鸦的，它是城市视觉表达中极其重要的一部分。在老虎和反涂鸦者之间的反复较量中，一场文化战争正在我们眼前展开。这种充满人情味的故事讲述了双方的立场，以及身处其中的感受——对外人来说，这似乎微不足道，但实际上
higher. This is California Love. Here's Walter Thompson Hernandez. It's spring 2017 and I'm on the 733 bus line heading west on Venezuela Boulevard. I'm sitting in the back of the bus. It's the early afternoon and there's nobody else sitting next to me. I'm listening to music on my headphones when I noticed an old friend hop on. It's Ivan and we used to be in the same circles when I used to tag in the early 2000s. Ivan hasn't changed for a bit.
至关重要。这里是《加州之爱》。我是沃尔特·汤普森-埃尔南德斯。那是2017年的春天，我正坐在733路公交车上，向西行驶在委内瑞拉大道上。我坐在车厢后部。那是刚过中午的时候，旁边没有其他人。我戴着耳机听着音乐，这时我注意到一个老朋友跳上了车。是伊万，21世纪初我玩涂鸦时，我们曾经在同一个圈子里。伊万一点也没变。
He still weren't oversized t-shirts and still speaks from the side of his mouth like he used to when we were teenagers. His hair still cut really low too. It's been more than 15 years since we last saw one another. Oh s**t. What's up man? We dabbing each other up and hug. He sits next to me.
他仍然穿着加大码T恤，说话时还是像我们当青少年时那样习惯用嘴角出声。他的头发也依然剃得很短。距离我们上次见面已经过去15年多了。噢，靠。老兄，最近怎么样？我们击掌拥抱。他在我旁边坐下。
Hey you still right? Yeah. I do still right. This is Live, and I was wearing the gray crew neck sweater and matching sweat pants at the officers at Issue Timmy. My last name was written on the back of my sweater to identify me. In 97, the scarier straight program meant at the downtime at LA Central Police Station three times a week. Twice a week we had classes and on Saturdays, that's when we had boot camp.
嘿，你还在写吗？对。我还在写。这是李，当时我穿着灰色的圆领运动衫和配套的运动裤，上面印着警局的标志。我的姓氏写在毛衣背面以便辨认。在97年，警钟长鸣项目意味着每周去洛杉矶中央警察局三次。我们一周有两天上课，星期六则是我们参加集训的日子。
They made us do push-ups, burpees, squats, spritz, and more burpees and all on the station's hot roof. About two dozen of us all under the age of 17, were in the program. Usually because of the judge had ordered us to attend for some crime we had committed. One of the guys was a graffiti legend named Sight, a South Central writer whose name could be seen throughout the city.
他们让我们做俯卧撑、立卧撑跳、深蹲、冲刺，还有更多的立卧撑跳，全都在警局炽热的屋顶上进行。我们大约有二十来人，全都在17岁以下，参加了这个项目。通常是因为法官命令我们出席，因为我们犯了罪。其中有个家伙是个涂鸦传奇人物，叫Sight，他是中南部的一个写手，他的名字在整个城市随处可见。
He was what writers called an all-city bomber. His stuff was everywhere. I was like, damn, that's sight. What I do remember is all the cops getting mad at me, screaming at me in my face. The saliva, all of my face. Do not touch my face! Some people were there for skipping school, fighting or violating probation. Beside a night, we were both there for a graffiti vandalism. I started tagging with a group of friends I had met in middle school.
他就是写手们所说的“全城轰炸客”。他的作品无处不在。我当时想，天哪，那是Sight。我记得的是所有警察都对我发火，冲着我的脸大喊大叫。口水喷了我一脸。不准碰我的脸！有些人去那里是因为逃学、打架或违反缓刑规定。除了Sight，我们两个都是因为涂鸦破坏。我和在初中结识的一群朋友开始一起玩涂鸦。
And once I learned how to tag, I began to go out and paint the streets. Maybe it was all the things I was seeing and experiencing at home that drove me to be as far away from it as possible. My mom had a boyfriend at the time. This white dude who was unemployed and smoke weed and drank heavily every single day. He was abusive and controlling towards me and my mom and he and I would often physically fight which led to numerous visits from the police. Home was definitely summer I didn't want to be. In sight, home life, it was just as rocky as mine. Me and my mom were sleeping in parks and in the car, eating peanut butter and jelly sandwiches for night.
一旦我学会了涂鸦，我便开始走上街头进行涂绘。也许是我在家中所看到和经历的一切，驱使我尽可能地远离那个地方。当时我妈妈有个男朋友。这个白人无所事事，每天抽大麻酗酒。他对我和我妈妈有虐待欲和控制欲，我和他经常发生肢体冲突，导致警察屡次上门。家绝对是我不想待的地方。对Sight来说，家庭生活也和我的 一样糟糕。我和我妈妈睡在公园里和车里，晚上吃花生酱果冻三明治。
We slept in a lot of back streets, in South Central LA, like Western, Imperial. And then the sharps will kick us out. And we'll move on one block over. graffiti was a lot of things for me. It was an outlet. A way for me to take out the rage, the pain, and the hurt I was experiencing at home.
我们睡在洛杉矶中南部的好多后街里，比如韦斯顿街、帝国高速路。然后保安会把我们赶走。我们就搬到隔壁街区。涂鸦对我有许多意义。它是一个宣泄口。是我释放我在家中感受到的愤怒、痛苦和伤痛的一种方式。
The streets and the walls, they're basically my therapy. I existed when I did graffiti. I existed. That's why I started doing that sense of awakening, rebirth. The first Saturday that sat and I were there, the inmates and guards took turns yelling at us. And he and I smelt at each other the whole time. Ha! We thought they were suckers. Our moms were both with us that day, and when you the guards couldn't put their hands on us,
街道和墙壁，基本上就是我的心理治疗。当我进行涂鸦时，我是存在的。我是存在的。这就是我开始这样做的原因——那种觉醒感、重生的感觉。我和Sight在那里的第一个星期六，犯人和看守轮流对我们大喊大叫。他和我在整个过程中相视而笑。哈！我们觉得他们都是白痴。那天我们的妈妈们都在场，而且当你看守不能对我们动粗时，
so we felt safe, and we talked our s**t. The scare straight? It actually didn't scare me straight. In fact, it got me deeper into graffiti. About two years after I finished the program, I started catching spots with a guy named Aloe. He was a pretty well known writer in the graph world. In the crazy part, he looked just like one of my favorite rappers.
所以我们感到很安全，我们开始口无遮拦。“警钟长鸣”？它其实并没有把我吓回正道。事实上，它让我更深地陷入了涂鸦之中。结束这个项目大约两年后，我开始和一个叫Alo的家伙一起到处留名。他在涂鸦界是个相当出名的写手。最疯狂的是，他长得极像我最喜欢的说唱歌手之一。
Yeah, everyone used to call me Tupac. In just a few months, we became like brothers, and we joined the same crew. You were young and willing to do graffiti, so I was like, hey, we could be besties and let's do this together. I'll talk about an overhead right now, but he's really only three years older than me. He and I spent every day together painting the city. This means going out and tagging. I remember there were times I'm like, I don't really feel like doing this.
对，每个人以前都叫我图派克。短短几个月内，我们就像亲兄弟一样，加入了同一个涂鸦团伙。你当时很年轻，又愿意玩涂鸦，所以我当时就想，嘿，我们可以成为死党，一起搞这个。我现在说的是一个大人物，但他其实只比我大三岁。我和他每天都泡在一起装扮这座城市。这意味着出门到处涂鸦。我记得有时我心想，我其实不太想做这个。
He's like, come on, let's go. And I'm like, all right, let's go. And we would go and then it's like, once we're there, it's like, so glad like I did this. There's a lot of people, like I knew a lot of people too, and not everyone, they'll say, oh yeah, yeah, let's go, let's go. But who really wants to go? Who's really gonna go?
他说，来吧，我们走。我说，好吧，走吧。然后我们就会去，一旦到了那里，就会觉得，太庆幸我做了这件事。有很多人，比如我也认识很多人，并不是每个人都会说，哦耶，走吧，走吧。但谁又是真的想去呢？谁又真的会去呢？
Alo and I spent a whole summer together, and our bond was stronger than any relationship I've had as an adult. Because he was also unhappy, and temperamented by his home life. We were just kids, but we understood each other's pain and how ignored we both felt. Alo taught me how to tag on the municipal of our bus lines. We caught spots in the panels and the overhead lights. I taught him how to do everything that he knows.
Alo和我一起度过了整个夏天，我们的羁绊比我成年后经历过的任何关系都要深厚。因为他同样不快乐，备受家庭生活折磨。我们只是孩子，但我们理解彼此的痛苦，以及我们都觉得自己被忽视得有多彻底。Alo教我如何在市营公交车线路上涂鸦。我们在车窗和顶灯上留下印记。我则教他他所知道的一切。
Shut up! So, describing him into a transparent case, so people wouldn't be able to see it. There has to be some way for you to make what you just wrote, pop out into the world. So usually what we would do is we would take dirt from somewhere. So we lick our fingers and rub the tops of the lights. You would smudge that on the spot. The dirt would end up filling the spaces of the graffiti spot that you just caught.
闭嘴！所以，把它描述成一个透明的盒子，这样人们就看不到了。你必须想个办法，让你刚才写的东西在世界上显眼。所以通常我们做的是，我们会从某个地方弄点土。然后我们舔舔手指，擦拭灯顶。你会把土涂抹在那个地方。这些泥土最终会填满你刚刚留下的涂鸦的缝隙。
Bam! Now your spot's gonna be seen. I used to show them different slap tags and how you ride on a slap tag. For those of you that don't know, post office used to have stickers that people use for mailing and graffiti artists would just go and grab them. They're free stickers, we could just write what we want on them. We sometimes go back to Adelos House after painting and lock ourselves in this room.
砰！现在你的涂鸦就能被看到了。我过去常常向他们展示不同的贴纸涂鸦，以及如何在贴纸涂鸦上书写。对于那些不知道的人来说，邮局过去有供人们寄信使用的贴纸，涂鸦艺术家会直接去拿。它们是免费贴纸，我们可以在上面写任何我们想写的东西。画画完后，有时我们会回到阿德洛的家里，把自己锁在这个房间里。
Just smoking, drinking there, playing music, a lot of wood, a lot of two-puck. A lot of knives, a lot of biggie. Just right, just right, just right. We wrote our names all over the city because we found invisible and it was fun. I existed when I did graffiti. I existed. We painted fewer overpasses, national boulevards, Robertson, Crenshaw. We painted billboards on Venice boulevards.
就在那里抽烟、喝酒、放音乐，放很多武当帮的歌，很多图派克。放很多纳斯，很多大gie。就是这样，就是这样，这就是节奏。我们在城市的各处写下我们的名字，因为我们感觉自己隐形了，而且这很有趣。当我进行涂鸦时，我是存在的。我是存在的。我们在威尼斯大道、罗伯逊大道、克伦肖大道的立交桥上画过。我们在威尼斯大道的广告牌上画过。
We painted out the Belmont yards, the Alley River and the Monty Yards. We were everywhere. But our names rarely stayed out for more than a few days. For four years I tagged, and for four years a white dude named Joe Connolly painted over our spots. 98, 99, 2000, and 2001. The sky Joe made it his mission to buff our tags using paint and equipment he had purchased himself. Seeing him buff out my throw-ups wasn't a good feeling because creating that art took a lot out of me. Like this one time, when I spent an entire night doing a piece with large bubble-style
我们在贝尔蒙特调车场、阿利河和蒙蒂调车场画过。我们无处不在。但我们的名字很少能保留超过几天。我玩了四年涂鸦，而一个叫乔·康利（Joe Connolly）的白人花了四年时间把我们的涂鸦刷掉。1998年、1999年、2000年和2001年。这家伙乔把清除我们的涂鸦当成了自己的使命，他使用的是自己出钱买的油漆和设备。看到他把我的喷漆涂鸦刷掉可不是什么好感觉，因为创作那些艺术耗费了我极大的心血。就像有一次，我在佩科和罗伯逊附近的屋顶上花了一整夜创作了一幅带有巨大气泡风格字母的作品，
letters on the rooftop near Peacol & Roberson, and it was gone the very next morning, and I knew it was Joe. And it wasn't just us, it was all of us. There was a whole city of kids putting up spots trying to be seen, and then this white guy named Joe would come out at any races again. Joe was definitely a villain. It felt like he was our villain. You could ride all day long, but you're never going to get up in the morning so you
结果第二天早上它就没了，我知道那是乔干的。而且不只是我们，我们所有人都是如此。整座城市有成百上千的孩子到处涂鸦试图引起注意，然后这个叫乔的白人就会出来把它们全擦掉。乔绝对是个恶棍。感觉他就是我们的恶棍。你可以一整天都在到处乱写，但你绝对不可能在早上看到你的
s**t because I'll be buffed. You couldn't even read the sign earlier. You could not read the sign. It means Joe Connolly. They call me the graffiti gorilla among other things. Look at that, not beautiful. I mean, it's not like it was with the day that made it, but it's nice. Isn't that nice, look at it? Joe was a one-man antigraphy unit. You may have seen his infamous sign up at Peaco and Fairfax, it says. The graffiti no longer accepted here sign up at Peaco and Fairfax, it says.
作品，因为会被刷掉。你刚才甚至都读不出那个标志。你根本读不出那个标志。那就是乔·康利。他们管我叫“涂鸦大猩猩”之类的。看那个，不漂亮吗？我是说，它不如刚做出来那天那么新，但也挺好看。不是很漂亮吗，看看它？乔是一个人的反涂鸦小队。你可能在佩科和费尔法克斯见过他那块声名狼藉的牌子，上面写着。佩科和费尔法克斯的标志上写着“此处不再接受涂鸦”。
Graffiti no longer accepted here. Please find a day job. Thank you, 1993. Joe Condo the Graffiti Gorilla. Joe used to chase us out of the modiards and paint over our spots. We all thought he was a sitting employee, but really joked it alone. After the King writes, a neighbor organized out the building was still burned out, trees didn't want to get planned. They're all these people wanted to fix the neighborhood, helicopters were, so I went to this meeting
此处不再接受涂鸦。请去找一份正经工作。谢谢，1993年。乔·康道，“涂鸦大猩猩”。乔过去常常把我们从蒙蒂调车场赶跑，并把我们的涂鸦刷掉。我们都以为他是市政雇员，但其实乔是在单枪匹马干这事。在国王写手事件后，一个邻居组织清理这座建筑仍然被烧毁，树木不想被种植。有这么多人都想修复这个街区，直升机在盘旋，所以我去参加了这次会议，
and they had all these things that they wanted people to do was like seven or eight of us there. So I'm sitting and I'm thinking, I'm not gonna say anything. I'm not volunteering for, I mean, I'm working seven days a week, I got two little kids, I'm making money. I'm not, so they said graffiti was the last thing on the other thing.
他们提出了所有希望人们去做的的事情，当时大概有七八个人在那里。所以我坐着心想，我什么都不会说。我不会主动去干，我是说，我每周工作七天，我有两个小孩，我在赚钱。我才不，所以他们说涂鸦是最后一件事。
They said you're taking graffiti. I'm like, yeah, cool. That would be excellent, because there's no graffiti around. I go out the next day and I start driving around. I'm like, oh my God. Okay, we out, right? to chill. And then, at 4am, I got a weird craving for Hawaiian punch, so we decided to walk the raft. And then, you took a streak, and then, for some stupid reason, I was like, hey, let's record this. And I took this video camera that I had. We didn't make it to the store. We crossed the street and you
他们说你去管涂鸦吧。我心想，好吧，太酷了。那将是极好的，因为周围没有涂鸦。我第二天出门开始四处开车。我心想，天哪。好吧，我们出去玩，对吧？去放松一下。然后，在凌晨4点，我突然对夏威夷果汁产生了奇怪的渴望，于是我们决定步行去那个小卖部。然后，你拐进了一条小巷，接着，出于某种愚蠢的原因，我心想，嘿，我们把这个录下来吧。我拿出了我带的摄像机。我们没有走到商店。我们过了马路，然后你
decided to start tagging on a trash cab. And my dumbass instead of looking out looking back I'm looking through the lens at you and police pulled up on us. The cops handcuffed us, made us sit on the curb, and then separated us for questioning. I was already on probation for a previous graffiti offense. I thought I was for sure going to Juvie. The cops asked me, back then I hadn't started also using my mom's last name Hernandez. So I said, Walter Thompson, and the cops were like, That's not your name. That's what I was lying to him.
决定开始在一个垃圾桶上涂鸦。而我这个笨蛋没有放哨，反而透过镜头看着你，这时警察把车开到了我们身边。警察给我们戴上手铐，让我们坐在马路牙子上，然后把我们分开盘问。因为之前的涂鸦违规行为，我当时还在缓刑期。我当时觉得我进少管所是板上钉钉了。警察问我，那时候我还没开始用我妈妈的姓氏埃尔南德斯。所以我说，沃尔特·汤普森，警察却说，这不是你的名字。那是我在对他说谎。
They thought Walter Thompson sounded like an 80 year old white dude's name. And now that I'm thinking about it, they were kind of right. I remember them asking me about that. So what's your friend's name? And I was like, bezel? Because I was not trying to give up your name. I didn't know what she said. So I was like, bezel and the cop was like, What the fuck are you doing? I was like, I don't know, I to give up your name. I didn't know what she said. So I was like, bezel. And the cop was like, what the fuck am I?
他们觉得沃尔特·汤普森听起来像是个80岁白人老头的名字。现在回想起来，他们还真没猜错。我记得他们盘问我这件事。所以你朋友叫什么名字？我说，贝索？因为我绝不想供出你的名字。我不知道她说了什么。所以我说，贝索，然后警察说，你他妈在搞什么鬼？我说，我不知道，我想供出你的名字。我不知道她说了什么。所以我说，贝索。然后警察说，你他妈到底在——
I was like, I don't know. I don't know his name. Because I was like, maybe he's not going to give his name. So Aloe and I start laughing at the cops when I believe in me. But the cops, they didn't think it was funny. They got mad and they got frustrated. And put us in separate cars and took us back to the station. I went home after three hours. But A Ella, he was there for almost three days.
我说，我不知道。我不知道他的名字。因为我想，也许他不会说出自己的名字。于是Alo和我开始嘲笑不相信我的警察。但警察可不觉得好笑。他们生气了，沮丧了。把我们塞进不同的警车里带回了警局。我三小时后就回家了。但Alo，他在那里被关了将近三天。
If you look at this Nomea's site, SIGHT, to Mom kicking me out when I graduated from high school. She kicked me out because she thought she could afford to take care of me anymore. So here I am thinking I'm about to get ready to go to Community College. Nope. I used to sleep in my home, he's a garage. I used to sleep in the garage with a dog right here, normally, the end of 76. Because he couldn't let me stay in his house, but he's like, yeah, I got a garage. And sometimes me and a dog are fight over who will sleep on the couch.
如果你看看这个叫Sight的家伙，SIGHT，我高中毕业时我妈把我赶出了家门。她把我赶出去是因为她觉得她再也养不起我了。所以我当时以为我正准备去社区大学上学。没门。我以前睡在我朋友的家里，他的车库。我以前和一个狗睡在车库里，就在这儿，正常情况下，在76号街尽头。因为他不能让我留在他家里，但他对我说，好吧，我有间车库。有时候我和那条狗还要争夺谁睡在沙发上。
That's where graffiti really kicked in the high gear because I was out depressed, lonely, hungry. And this is only the end of my spirit to letting that trauma out during graffiti. There's a human need to express yourself. Unfortunately the lower classes and the impoverished don't have the spaces and the walls to this be creative. They don't own nothing.
那就是涂鸦真正进入全盛期的时候，因为我当时既沮丧、孤独又饥饿。这也是我将这种创伤通过涂鸦宣泄出来的精神所在。人有表达自我的需求。不幸的是，下层阶级和贫困人口没有空间和墙壁来发挥这种创造力。他们什么都不拥有。
They can't write in their own apartment building and they can get kicked out. They don't have a house doing the backyard. So where are they gonna do that? The streets where they can't be. They got stars, and they got, they got can't control. It's popping at the top. This something's been in the game for a while. This is nice.
他们不能在自己的公寓楼里乱写，否则会被赶出去。他们没有带后院的房子。那他们要去哪里做这件事呢？只能去街道上，他们不能去的地方。他们有电线杆，他们有——他们有变电箱。它在顶部冒出来。这个东西在这个圈子里已经有一段时间了。这挺好的。
Once I started noticing it and all that, I got interested in it and then I started studying it and going out, mainly with taggers. Isn't that s***? And I said, look, I just wanna travel with you guys. They're like, oh, you stupid, boy, but I'm like, okay. I said, well, I'm gonna learn about this no matter what. I just wanna learn.
一旦我开始注意到它以及所有这些，我对它产生了兴趣，然后我开始研究它，并经常和涂鸦写手们一起出去。这不扯淡吗？我对他们说，看，我只想和你们一起去。他们说，哦，你这个笨蛋男孩，但我说，好吧。我说，不管怎样我都要了解这个。我只是想了解。
See that, see where skinny and goes up and it pops right there with that little circle? That's called can't control. There's nobody, I don't think there's anybody in the world that gets graffiti like me. I don't I don't it would take a lot A lot of people get they don't get that graffiti has to start with all these tags And then it moves to a throwrup and then it can be a mirror and it can be a burner it can be a production it can you know and so only a small amount of people are going to be able to get to To the art side of it the real art side of it whatever that might be and then make a living out that's cool
看到那个没，看到线条变细然后那个小圆圈往上翘的地方吗？那叫变电箱。世界上没有人，我觉得没有人像我一样懂涂鸦。我不——我不会——这需要很多——很多人不明白涂鸦必须从所有这些标签开始，然后发展成喷绘，然后它可以是一幅壁画，它可以是一个精细作品，它可以是一个作品组合，它可以是——你知道的，所以只有少数人能够接触到艺术层面，真正的艺术层面，无论那可能是什么，然后靠这个谋生，那挺酷的。
But if they don't they don't allow the tag they won't get there and if in the world would really suck if we didn't have graffiti. I'm okay, yeah, some of this stuff takes a while to get to, but if you get out of every day, it takes no time. I don't get excited by graffiti. It doesn't bother me that it keeps going up. It has to go up, otherwise the artist can't emerge. And they should be entitled to emerge. I mean, it's, and a lot of them, their stories are interesting to hear. Well, I'll kind of can read it. So why would I keep painting out graffiti if, if I enjoy it?
但如果他们不这样，他们就不会允许标签的存在，他们也就无法达到那个境界，如果世界上没有涂鸦，那将真的很糟糕。我没关系，是的，其中一些东西需要一段时间才能掌握，但如果你每天都出来，那就不费时间了。我对涂鸦并不感到兴奋。它一直出现并没有困扰我。它必须出现，否则艺术家就无法涌现。而他们应该有权涌现。我是说，这——而且他们当中很多人的故事听起来都很有趣。好吧，我差不多能看懂。所以我为什么要一直把涂鸦刷掉呢，如果——如果我乐在其中？
Because A, they have to do it. Two, they expected to get painted out. And three, kind of gives them a fresh canvas to keep going. It all sounds like bulls**t to me too. How could somebody love graffiti so much and spend every single day destroying it? It doesn't really add up, right? It sounds like something he says in front of Tagger
因为第一，他们必须这么做；第二，他们料到自己的作品会被刷掉；第三，这在某种程度上为他们提供了继续创作的新画布。这一切听起来对我来说也是一派胡言。怎么会有人这么热爱涂鸦，却又花上整整每一天去摧毁它？这根本说不通，对吧？听起来就像他在涂鸦者面前说的话一样，
so that he won't get beat up. A top set, your mom's here, you're out. After getting arrested that night with Aloe, I changed my life. My mom was a reason. She picked me up from the station at 6 a.m., and it wasn't the first time. But there was something about that ninth,
这样他就不会挨揍了。顶部设置，你妈来了，你出局了。那天晚上和Alo一起被捕后，我改变了生活。我妈妈是原因。她早上6点把我从警局接了回来，这已经不是第一次了。但那天晚上有些不一样，
I was different. She looked worn out. She looked like a mom who had no more fight left in her. I was really tired of disappointing her. I was afraid of her being afraid for me. And I knew I had to change things up. I remember trying to call you and like you were avoiding me. And then I finally got a hold of you
我变了。她看起来筋疲力尽。她看起来像一个再也没有力气抗争的母亲。我真的厌倦了让她失望。我害怕她为我担惊受怕。我知道我必须做出改变。我记得我曾试图给你打电话，而你好像在躲着我。然后我终于联系上了你，
and then you said something like, oh, I'm just kind of busy right now. And I was like, you busy for me? What the fuck wrong, what's going on right now? Please leave a message and come to the tone. I stopped answering his calls. Yeah, like you just pretty much ghost me from right there. I started going to class again. It was just like, yeah, what the hell, there was.
接着你说了一些类似“哦，我现在有点忙”的话。然后我说，你忙着不理我？到底怎么回事，现在出什么事了？请留言并在哔声后说话。我不再接听他的电话。是的，就像你从那一刻起直接把我当空气一样。我又开始去上课了。当时的感觉就像是，管他呢，就是这样。
I started playing basketball again. So I'm getting cheery as I'm seeing this right now. I stopped smoking weed and drinking too. After that, I just... I think I couldn't find anyone else to really connect with. And then I actually started getting more into into fighting for some reason. I was never a big fighter, but all of a sudden I'm like Mr. Motro Man and I want to fight everybody. My best friend and I wouldn't see her talk to each other for 17 years.
我又开始打篮球了。我现在看到这幕都快感动得流泪了。我也戒掉了抽大麻和喝酒。那之后，我只是……我觉得我再也找不到其他人能真正建立联系了。然后我实际上出于某种原因开始更多地投入到打架中。我从来都不是个好斗的人，但突然之间我变成了猛男先生，我想和所有人打架。我和我最好的朋友有17年没有见面或说话。
It was one of the hardest choices I ever made because I left friends behind who I considered a family. And it hit the hardest when I'd see their names on walls and not my own. It felt like they carried on with their lives and forgot about me. And it was harder because deep inside, I knew that it was something I brought up on myself. I left the world where I was completely seen, only to re into a world where being seen wasn't guaranteed. And for a 14 year old, it was all really confusing. I wanted to change. And soon, the entire Alligua Fita world would also change.
这是我做过最艰难的选择之一被我抛在脑后的朋友曾被我视为家人。而最让人心痛的是，当我在墙上看到他们的名字却没有我自己的名字时。感觉他们继续过着他们的生活，却把我忘得一干二净。更难受的是，内心深处我知道这一切都是我自找的。我离开了那个我被完全看见的世界，却重新投入了一个无法保证被看见的世界。对于一个14岁的孩子来说，这一切都太让人困惑了。我想要改变。不久之后，整个洛杉矶涂鸦世界也将发生改变。
We return with more California love after this. By 2006, sight had briefly stepped back from graffiti. He was no longer homeless, but his mom was. He was working to save money to buy his mama home because he wanted to rescue her from the park she was sleeping in. He was going to school at a community college and working two jobs. And my grandmother was like, after she saw how productive I was and how serious I was, she was like, look, why don't you just live here?
稍后我们将为您带来更多《加州之爱》。到2006年，Sight已经短暂退出了涂鸦界。他不再无家可归，但他妈妈依然如此。他努力工作攒钱给妈妈买个房子，因为他想把她从她一直睡觉的公园里解救出来。他当时在上社区大学，还打着两份工。我外祖母看到我表现得这么有生产力、这么认真之后，就对我说，听着，你为什么不直接住在这里呢？
About the time I walked away from graffiti, what used to be a misdemeanor offense was now a felony. Graffiti artists started doing hard time for their art. Some people in Outlay refer to this time as a terror campaign. It's when taggers homes were reportedly being rated, like they were drug dealers or members of a violent gang. It was a perfect sunny day at St. St. John's LA. As Q. We say, in a couple days before Thanksgiving, 2006. You hear loud bangs on the door?
就在我远离涂鸦的那段时间里，曾经的轻罪现在成了重罪。涂鸦艺术家们开始因为他们的艺术而遭受牢狱之灾。加州的一些人把这段时间称为一场恐怖运动。据报道，当时涂鸦写者的家遭到突击搜查，就像他们是毒贩或暴力黑帮成员一样。那是圣佩德罗一个完美晴朗的日子。正如我们所说，在2006年感恩节前几天。你听到门被砰砰砸响？
I'm in a bed naked. Sleep. My auntie go open the door. I told her, don't open the door. I don't know who that is. She open the door. I'm in the bed naked sleep my auntie go open the door She open the door anyway The police come in looking like they're in war gear Just like seven eight of them on top of your head put your hands on top of your head They got assault rifles with beams coming out of them. They pulled me out into the main din and they're like,
我光着身子在床上睡觉。我阿姨去开门。我告诉她，别开门。我不知道那是谁。她去开门了。我光着身子在床上睡觉，我阿姨去开门她还是把门打开了警察冲进来，看起来像穿了作战装备一样足足七八个人压在你头上把你的手按在头上他们手里拿着带激光瞄准器的突击步枪他们把我拖到主起居室里，问我：
where are the drugs and where are the guns? I'm like, there's no drugs and guns here. You got the wrong person. You got right at the wrong house. There's no drugs or guns. They're like, where is the guns and the drugs? Do you want to check these? I think it's worth it.
毒品在哪里？枪在哪里？我说，这里没有毒品和枪。你们抓错人了。你们找对人了但找错房子了。这里没有毒品或枪支。他们说，枪和毒品在哪里？你想检查这些吗？我觉得这很值得。
They're tearing up the whole house. They put some shoes on me, no socks, pants, no belt, shirt, handcuffs me. They walk me outside. We got a whole neighborhood outside watching, you know, those are people be. They took me down to the sheriff's station and on Watts. And they were high five and they were high five and they were like, yeah, we got this door.
他们把整栋房子砸得稀巴烂。他们给我套上一双鞋，没穿袜子，套上裤子但没有皮带，穿上衬衫，给我戴上手铐。他们把我带到外面。整个社区的人都在外面看着，你知道，大家都是这样的。他们把我带到瓦茨的警局。他们击掌相庆，他们击掌欢呼着说，太好了，我们抓到这个家伙了。
We've been looking for this door for every, I'm like, wow. When I'm out through my head on line, I didn't know graffiti is this serious. If I knew graffiti was this serious, then I wouldn't have met messing with it. And get me an interrogation room. I don't know law, send me down. They sit down a folder of paperwork about six inches tall. All photos of stuff I did in LA. And they open a folder, pictures and I might do this.
我们到处在找这个家伙，我说，哇。当我把这些抛诸脑后时，我根本不知道涂鸦这么严重。如果我知道涂鸦这么严重，那我根本不会去碰它。他们把我带进审讯室。我不懂法律，就把我晾在那儿。他们放下厚厚一叠大约六英寸高的文件。全是我在洛杉矶干那些事的照片。他们翻开文件夹，里面全都是照片，问我这是不是我干的。
All, the stuff was all old, dude. There were like, if you date these, till more recent date, we'll let you out today. I'm like, for real. But, it wasn't for real. Sight was charged with multiple accounts of non-violent felony vandalism.
所有这些东西都很旧，老兄。他们说，如果你在这些照片上标上更近的日期，我们今天就放你出去。我说，真的吗？但是，这不是真的。Sight被控多项非暴力重罪破坏罪。
He says the evidence he signed ended up being used against him in court. According to him, they had him date pictures of his tax to a more recent time, to land within the statute of limitations. Sight was facing around 30 years in prison, so he did what he had to do, and he took a deal for eight years and eight months. His sentencing was just part of the city's draconian antigraphy movement, and multiple hometown heroes like him were arrested.
他说，他签名的证据最终在法庭上对对他不利。据他所称，他们让他把涂鸦照片上的日期标得更近一些，以便落入追诉时效内。Sight面临大约30年的监禁，所以他只能顺从，接受了八年零八个月的认罪协议。他的判刑只是该市严厉的反涂鸦运动的一部分，多位像他这样的家乡英雄被捕。
City attorneys say, it's about time, taggers are treated like criminal gang members. In 2009, then Allys City Attorney Carmen Truchanich had a mission to go after writers. He and his staff began to gather street-level intelligence and prepare injunctions targeting graffiti crews. While sight was in prison, a lot of taggers reached out to him to provide support, including one he didn't know that well,
城市检察官表示，是时候把涂鸦者当作犯罪黑帮成员来对待了。2009年，当时的洛杉矶城市检察官卡门·特鲁查尼奇（Carmen Trutanich）将打击涂鸦写手定为自己的使命。他和他的团队开始收集街头情报，并准备针对涂鸦团伙发出禁止令。Sight在监狱服刑期间，许多涂鸦者联系他以示支持，其中包括一个他不太熟的人，
but who I used to be really tight with. Alou wrote me while I was in prison. I met him only once in person on the minutes bus. I never hung out with him like that. He went to prison for something that we were all doing. That could have been any one of us is what I'm saying. So it's like, you got to pay respect to him. For him to only meet me that once or twice
但却是我以前非常交好的人。我在监狱时Alo给我写了信。我只在公交车上见过他本人一次。我从来没跟他那样闲晃过。他因为我们大家都在做的事情而锒铛入狱。我想说的是，那本可能是我们任何一个人。所以这就好比，你必须向他致敬。他只跟我见过那一两次面，
they want to be like, hey, I'm going to reach out to this dude. All I can say is graffiti did that. We wrote together every, yeah, like every three weeks or so. What am I doing? How's everything going? Just trying to see where his mind was at. I felt good, man. I felt like I wasn't alone.
就想要像这样，嘿，我要联系这家伙。我只能说，是涂鸦促成了这一切。我们一起创作，每隔三周左右吧。我当时在干嘛？一切都怎么样？只是想看看他心里在想什么。我感觉很好，老兄。我觉得我并不孤单。
I felt like I feed his biggers and what. There's more than what people think it is. I was in there for about five years because I was like good behavior, fire camp, all that stuff. And then he was like, you know, like a year or two if I got out, he was like, I'll pick you up from prison.
我觉得我喂了这些混蛋什么的好吧。事情远比人们想象的要多。我在里面呆了大约五年，因为我表现好、参加了消防营之类的一切。然后他说，你知道的，等我出来的一两年后，他说，我会去监狱接你。
And he did they pick me up. Then my first meal took me down the Venice Beach. Bringing the salty air, you had to crash at the ocean, put my feet in the water. It was good man but I felt I felt broken, I felt vulnerable. This is just all of our stuff to get rid of that. The graffiti. We think, we think this all we need. We're not 100% sure. Well, the city, you know, they, they, they, I hate to say they killed my kid to this day they never apologized about that.
他确实这么做了，他们接了我。然后我的第一顿饭是带我去威尼斯海滩。吹着咸湿的海风，不得不去海边，把双脚泡在水里。那种感觉很好，老兄，但我感觉自己支离破碎，我感觉自己很脆弱。这只是我们所有人摆脱那种困境的方式。涂鸦。我们以为，我们以为这就是我们所需要的。我们并不百分之百确定。好吧，这个城市，你知道，他们，他们，我讨厌说他们害死了我的孩子，直到今天他们从未为此道歉。
He went on a school field trip and died in a drowning incident. They had told Namah that there was gonna, there was never gonna be any swimming out there. They had told Namas that there was never going to be any swimming out there. The way it happened and all the things that happened in the city, the city could have helped me and they never chose to help me. They chose to desert me. They've never said, we're sorry about your son. That's I think one reason why staying graffiti abatement is because I'm not able to fix my
他去参加学校郊游，在一次溺水事故中丧生。他们曾告诉娜玛，那里绝对不会有任何游泳活动。他们曾告诉娜玛，那里绝对不会有任何游泳活动。事情发生的方式以及这座城市里发生的一切，这座城市本可以帮我，但他们从未选择帮我。他们选择抛弃我。他们从来没有说过，我们为你的儿子感到抱歉。我想这也是我坚持从事涂鸦清除工作的原因之一，因为我无法修复我的
life because you can't ever control. It's like trying to hurt cats, you can't control. So I can control graffiti, which makes people's lives better. So for me, it's just, I spend probably a small fortune on it, but it really saves me mentally. By 2015, I was working as a journalist and writing about race and identity. One day, I received a call from a child her friend, Nikki, telling me about the company she had just started in Compton. Nikki's company was primarily hiring undocumented workers and formerly incarcerated people
生活，因为你根本无法控制。这就像赶猫上树一样，你根本控制不了。但我可以控制涂鸦，这能让人们的生活变得更好。所以对我有用的是，我可能在上面花了一小笔财富，但它确实在精神上拯救了我。到2015年，我成为了一名记者，撰写关于种族和身份的文章。一天，我接到了一位童年好友尼基（Nikki）的电话，她向我讲述了她刚刚在康普顿创立的公司。尼基的公司主要雇佣无证工人和前服刑人员——
to groups of people who live with the most stigma. I walked inside of the lobby and saw a frame newspaper article featuring a black man standing in front of a graffiti wall. I took a step closer and he looked really familiar. I took another step forward and noticed that the wall read SIGHT in big and bold letters. It was sight. Oh damn, that's sight from Scarest Straight. Do you know a sight? I asked Nikki.
这两群生活在最多污名化之中的人。我走大大厅，看到了一张装裱起来的报纸文章，上面有一个黑人站在一面涂鸦墙前的照片。我走近了一步，觉得他看起来非常眼熟。我又往前迈了一步，注意到墙上用粗体大字写着SIGHT。是Sight。哦，天哪，那是“警钟长鸣”里的Sight。你认识Sight吗？我问尼基。
Sight? She replied, yeah he works here. He's actually in the back driving the fork lift. Let's go see if he's back there. What are the odds? The three of us went out to lunch that day and began reminiscing about scarce straight angriffiti Something told me to ask side about aloe because there weren't a lot of other black graffiti artists. So what I have to lose Aloe site replied. Yeah, that's my boy
Sight？她回答说，对，他就在这儿工作。他其实在后面开叉车呢。我们去后面看看他在不在。几率有多大？我们三人那天出去吃午饭，开始回忆起“警钟长鸣”和涂鸦。不知为什么，我有一种直觉，向Sight打听Alo的消息，因为当时黑人涂鸦艺术家并不多。我有什么好失去的呢？Sight回答说。对，那是我的好兄弟。
My jaw dropped all the way to the floor. Give me his number, I said. I called him and nobody answered. I went home after lunch and later that day received a phone call from an unknown number. I answered in this mysterious voice asked, Hey, is this best though? Hey, is this Bessau?
我的下巴差点惊得掉到地上。把他的电话给我，我说。我给他打电话，但没有人接。午饭后我回家了，那天晚些时候我接到一个陌生来电。我接起来，一个神秘的声音问，嘿，这是贝索吗？嘿，这是贝索吗？
Alo and I met up a week later at Earthcafe in downtown LA. I was nervous and I was scared. Because even though a lot of time had passed, I didn't know how he felt. Maybe he felt abandoned by me. When I saw him, he didn't really look like Tupac anymore. He now had a fro and tattoo sleeves halfway down his arms. Honestly, he looked like he had been through a lot, but he still had that same charming smile and that same laugh. So much had happened since we last saw one another.
一周后，我和Alo在洛杉矶市中心的Earth咖啡馆见面了。我很紧张，也很害怕。因为尽管已经过去了很长时间，我不知道他作何感想。也许他觉得被我抛弃了。当我看到他时，他看起来已经不太像图派克了。他现在留着爆炸头，两条手臂上纹满了刺青。老实说，他看起来经历了很多，但他依然带着那迷人的微笑和同样的笑声。自从我们上次见面以来，发生了太多的事。
He had gotten married, he had survived two drug overdoses, he's vegetarian, and of all things, like of all the things in the world, he was studying to become a lawyer, a lawyer. We talked about our families, about food, and our friends, and towards the end of the night, he looked at me and said he had something to give me. I was just like, hey, do you remember this? And I remember your face was just like, wow.
他结了婚，经历过两次药物过量濒死，成了一名素食主义者，而且最不可思议的是——在世上所有的职业中，他竟然在学习成为一名律师，一名律师。我们聊了各自的家庭、食物和朋友，在当晚即将结束时，他看着我，说他有东西要送给我。我当时就像，嘿，你还记得这个吗？我记得你的表情就像是，哇。
He handed me a slap tag. Remember those post office stickers he talked about earlier? Well, I had filled this one out the same night we got arrested. Before that, we were to wine punch craving. This slap tag got our names on it. It said Bezzo, it said Al-O, and it said our cruise. And he had kept this one slap tag through the years, through everything. And now I had that slap tag.
他递给我一张贴纸涂鸦。还记得我们之前聊过的那些邮局贴纸吗？嗯，我在我们被捕的当晚就填好了这一张。在那之前，我们还渴望着夏威夷果汁。这张贴纸涂鸦上写着我们的名字。上面写着贝索，写着Alo，还写了我们的涂鸦团伙。这些年来，经历了种种风雨，他一直留着这张贴纸涂鸦。现在，那张贴纸涂鸦在我手里了。
And it's one of the most important things in my life. Meaning up at Sighten-Alo, I'd prompt him to see what our own nemesis Joe was up to. Maybe it was closure I was seeking. I don't know. So I found Joe on the internet. I contacted him, and I spent a few days with him. It turns out Joe hasn't changed. He's still covering up for feeding
这是我生命中最珍贵的东西之一。在见到Sight和Alo之后，我萌生了去看看我们的死对头乔现在在干什么的想法。也许我一直在寻求一种了结。我不知道。于是我在网上找到了乔。我联系了他，并和他在一起度过了几天。事实证明，乔一点也没变。他依然在覆盖涂鸦，
and he's still doing it for free. I was wrong about Joe. This dude really surprised me. He lives in South Central with his wife and cares for interviews people. So I think she probably was in a yard where she was like a dog where there's a male slug. I really expected Joe to agree me
而且他依然是免费在做这件事。我以前对这家伙乔的看法大错特错了。这家伙真的让我大吃一惊。他和妻子住在中南部，照顾着一些人。所以我认为她可能曾在某个院子里，就像一条有雄性鼻涕虫的狗一样。我原本真以为乔会穿着一件红色MAGA帽来门口迎接我，但他没有。
at the door of a red mega hat on, but he did it. He does have an award from Trump though, for graffiti abatement, evolved things. President Trump, best guy in the planet for community in the state of California, 40 million people, and I know someone who's got one ofion in the state of California 40 million people and I know I'm the only one who's got one of those in the state of California. Anyway, Joe actually hates the government. These people don't give a f*** about our people.
不过他确实因为清除涂鸦获得过特朗普颁发的奖项，真是无奇不有。特朗普总统，加利福尼亚州社区里星球上最好的人，有四千万人口，而我知道有人在加州——加利福尼亚州有四千万人口，而我知道我是唯一一个在加州拥有这个奖项的人。不管怎样，乔其实挺恨政府的。这些人根本他妈不在乎我们的人。
What he means are everyday people working class folks and especially people of color. And Joe's also really into fitness. He's an abit bike rider, an former football player from the Southside of Chicago. Rudy, that's the guy's story. What do you mean, though? Remember the film Rudy? The class? That's the guy's story.
他的意思是普通人、工人阶级，尤其是少数族裔。而且乔也非常热爱健身。他是个狂热的自行车手，曾是来自芝加哥南区的橄榄球运动员。鲁迪，那就是这家伙的故事。你是什么意思？还记得电影《鲁迪》吗？那个班级？那就是这家伙的故事。
That was my thing, man. I wanted to be a walk-up football player, and D. And then that's the guy's story. He got there three years ahead of me and took my crazy. Oh well. Here we are. Yeah, here we are. I decided to bring Joe and Sight together because I wanted them to talk about how they
那曾是我的梦想，老兄。我想成为一名无偿入选的橄榄球运动员，然后——这就是这家伙的故事。他比我早去三年，抢了我的疯狂。好吧。我们在这儿。是的，我们在这儿。我决定把乔和Sight聚在一起，因为我想让他们谈谈彼此是如何
perceive one another. Sight thinks Joe was a part of the problem, you know? Just another white dude who's part of the system to lock the black and brown people. Joe, on the other hand, had never met Sight, the human. He buffed out a lot of his pieces but he didn't know the man. He thought Sight was just another dude from the hood who got caught up in the human. He buffed out a lot of his pieces but he didn't know the man. He thought sight was just another dude from the hood who got caught up in the system. So I invited both of them to my aunt's house to talk because it was a neutral space. I wanted both of them to feel as comfortable as possible. I mean I really didn't know what was going to happen. Sites like you know somebody who is really chill and really mad love but...
看待对方的。Sight认为乔是问题的一部分，你知道吗？只是另一个体制内的白人，负责把黑人和棕色人种关进监狱。而乔呢，他从未见过有血有肉的Sight。他刷掉了他的很多作品，但他并不认识这个人。他以为Sight只是贫民窟里另一个卷入体制的混混。所以我邀请他们两个到我阿姨家聊天，因为那是一个中立的空间。我希望他们两个尽可能感到自在。我是说我真的不知道会发生什么。Sight就像那种非常随和、非常深情的人，但是——
Site! Get your ass in here! Just kinda out there. Let's stop! Come on! Are you mad? So you still put the f***ing walls? Yeah? Yeah, you really? That's good. I like that.
Sight！给老子滚进来！有点像在外面。停下来！快来！你生气了吗？所以你还在涂那些他妈的墙吗？是吗？是啊，你真的还在？这挺好的。我喜欢这样。
I mean... I said at my aunt's dining table and talking about what they agreed on. Graffiti, when you're looking on the outside of it, it's just ugly, it's horrible, it's dissonant. But once you step foot into that world, it's a whole another perspective on the matter. You'll never be able to relate unless you hang out with graffiti artists or art graffiti artists. You'll never be able to relate.
我是说……我坐在我阿姨的餐桌旁，听他们讨论彼此赞同的观点。涂鸦，当你从外部去看时，它只是丑陋的、可怕的、不和谐的。但一旦你踏入那个世界，你对这件事就会有完全不同的视角。除非你和涂鸦艺术家或艺术涂鸦者混在一起，否则你永远无法理解。你永远无法感同身受。
It'll just be judging from the outside in. Insight with him messing around. He came ready. He even reached out to the graffiti community on Facebook to see if that had any questions for Joe. Do you wanna hear those questions? Yeah, let's go. Shy and blanks,
那只会是从外部进行的评判。而Sight这家伙在瞎胡闹。他可是有备而来。他甚至在Facebook上的涂鸦社群里发帖，看看大家对乔有没有什么问题。你想听听那些问题吗？行，我们开始吧。害羞与空白，
wanna know why you buffed out the rooftop in 92 and told him to get day jobs. I thought it was just funny. It was just funny. It came from an American Express commercial. Another person asked, why did you, some of the questions were really angry. It was just funny. It came from an American Express commercial. Another person asked, why did you... Some of the questions were really angry.
想知道为什么你在92年把屋顶刷白，还叫他们去找兼职。我以为这只是个玩笑。这只是个玩笑。它来自一个美国运通的广告。另一个人问，为什么你……有些问题真的很生气。这只是个玩笑。它来自一个美国运通的广告。另一个人问，为什么你……有些问题真的很生气。
That's CalTrans. CalTrans is so insane about how they buff burners. Saito Joe, he was really hated. A lot of people plotted on you, on they plotted on your family. Wow. A lot of people went out to your kids secretly. I can't say who.
那是加州交通局。加州交通局对他们清理涂鸦的做法简直疯狂。Saito Joe，他真的很招人恨。很多人在背后算计你，算计你的家人。哇。很多人偷偷去找你的孩子，我不能说是谁。
Okay. And it's almost similar to like, I don't like say it, I don't like be disrespectful, but like, you know how a cop goes out and shoots a kid or arrests kids, and people feel that pain forever. Yeah. It's kind of like the same. It seemed like the news that people went after Joe's kids
好吧。这有点类似于，我不想这么说，我不想不尊重人，但就像你知道警察开枪打死一个小孩或逮捕孩子那样，人们那种痛苦会永远挥之不去。是的。这有点像。看起来人们针对乔的孩子的消息
really affected him, especially since Joe had lost his son. He was physically shaken and he really let down his guard. Joe revealed a difference to him that people weren't used to seeing. It didn't feel like a performance anymore. It felt like we were finally getting the real Joe. After I lost my son, I lost my grandmother, my parents, my brothers, my in-laws, my sister-in-laws, a lot of artists, a lot of people I knew, a lot of people in my community. There was a time in like 99 through 0708 where there's a lot of funerals.
真的对他打击很大，尤其是乔已经失去了儿子。他受到了极大的震撼，也真的卸下了防备。乔展现出了人们不常看到的脆弱一面。这感觉不再像是一场表演。感觉我们终于看到了真正的乔。在我失去儿子之后，我失去了祖母、父母、兄弟、岳父母、小姨子，还有很多艺术家，很多我认识的人，我社区里的很多人。在99年到07、08年左右，有一段时间有很多葬礼。
There's just so many funerals and it just, I mean, it's a lot. And then with a lot of things that mainly with my son, and they're still fall off from that, which is now almost, it's almost 21 years. You know, and so I just kind of then just really became a lot. I don't mean to get you off, you know. No, no, no. You know, I've, I've, I've, I've met a lot of different
有太多的葬礼，我的意思是，这真的很多。然后伴随着很多事情，主要是关于我的儿子，现在依然有余波，也就是现在快要，快要21年了。你知道，所以这后来真的变成了很多。我不是故意打断你，你知道的。不，不，不。你知道，我，我，我，我见过很多不同的
graffiti artists, at least about a thousand of them, that I know more. I the same story as you? Are similar. Yeah. And I'm listening to you. I'm listening to you. And what people don't know and people forget is any kind of painting is therapeutic.
涂鸦艺术家，至少大约有一千个，我对他们了解更多。我和你有一样的故事吗？或者类似的。是的。我在听你说话。我在听你说话。人们不知道也常常忘记的是，任何形式的绘画都是一种治疗。
Yeah. Painting, doing art, activates one side of the brain that helps heal trauma. Yeah. Painting doing our activates one side of the brain that helps heal trauma. Yeah, you've been doing some trauma. I feel that the more the longer that person paints reflects how much healing they need and how much therapy that that painting provides, I still do it because I still suffered the trauma It acts has not been rooted yet uprooted. So and I see it in you You might not be doing graffiti, but you are painting over it. Oh, yeah, yeah, it is still in a way therapeutic and provides a sense of relief and
是的。绘画，进行艺术创作，会激活大脑的一侧，帮助治愈创伤。是的。绘画进行艺术创作会激活大脑的一侧，帮助治愈创伤。是的，你一直在经历一些创伤。我觉得一个人画画的时间越长，就越能反映出他们需要多少治愈，以及这种绘画能提供多少治疗。我还在继续画，因为我依然承受着那些尚未被连根拔起的创伤。所以我也在你身上看到了这一点。你可能不在画涂鸦，但你在用别的方式掩盖它。哦，是的，是的，它在某种程度上仍然具有治疗作用，并提供了一种解脱感，而且
The other side of that is that it's fun. It's competitive. And there's some people that are game, and so we were not. In that moment, I think Joe finally felt seen in her too. He wasn't in your face, Joe, the wild Joe, the Rarararal Joe, you know? He was soft, and he was gentle.
另一方面，这也是有趣的。充满竞争。有些人跃跃欲试，而我们没有。在那一刻，我想乔终于觉得也被别人看到了。他不再是那个咄咄逼人的乔，那个狂野的乔，那个喧闹的乔，你知道吗？他是温柔的，他是轻柔的。
And site, I'm pretty sure he felt the same way too. People see walls with graffiti on them and think that the people responsible for the tags are criminals. But it's hard to know that there's a whole life behind the spray paint that emerges on the wall. And to be real, it's impossible to see the things that people are dealing with at home. It's already hard enough being a teenager, but imagine not having a way to express yourself. That's really hard. Some see it as property damage, but what about the damage people are experiencing in their own lives?
而且，我很确定他也有同感。人们看到墙上的涂鸦，就会认为做记号的人是罪 criminals。但很难知道出现在墙上的喷漆背后其实有着整个人生。说实话，根本无法看到人们在家里正在经历什么。做青少年已经够难了，但想象一下没有办法表达自己。那真的很难。有些人认为这是财产破坏，但人们在自己生活中经历的破坏又该怎么算呢？
Each piece of graffiti is a window to someone's life. Sometimes though, the window is hard to see through because there's writing on it. But each window and each wall tells a different story. The walls are the first thing I see when I travel to a new place. They tell me everything I need to know about where I'm at. They alert me of danger. Tell me who lives in that community. And who I need to be aware of. Let's go back to that bus.
每一幅涂鸦都是通往某人生活的窗户。有时，这扇窗户很难看透，因为上面写满了字。但每一扇窗户和每一面墙都讲述着不同的故事。当我到一个新地方时，墙壁是我看到的第一件事。它们告诉我关于我所在地方的一切所需信息。它们提醒我注意危险。告诉我谁住在那个社区。以及我需要防范谁。让我们回到那辆巴士上。
Spring, 2017. I'm on the 733 bus line and we're heading west on Venice Boulevard. I'm sitting in the back of the bus. It's the early afternoon and there's nobody else sitting next to me. I'm listening to music on my headphones when I notice an old friend hop on. It's Ivan and we used to be in the same circles when I used to tag. Ivan has a change for one bit. He's still wearing oversized t-shirts and still speaks from the side of his mouth like he
2017年春。我坐上了733路公交车，我们正向西开往威尼斯大道。我坐在巴士的后排。那是下午早些时候，我旁边没有其他人。我戴着耳机听音乐，这时我注意到一个老朋友跳上了车。是伊万（Ivan），我以前玩涂鸦时我们曾在同一个圈子里。伊万一点也没变。他依然穿着超大号T恤，说话时还是像以前那样
used to. In his hair, it's still cut really low. It's been more than 15 years since we last saw one another. Oh f***, what's up man? We dab each other up and hug, and he sits right next to me. Hey, you still right? When I even asked me if I still wrote, I paused. Because the truth is, nothing's really changed. I am still writing. I'm just not writing on walls or buses or freeways anymore. But I'm still writing
从嘴的一侧吐出字来。他的头发依然剪得很短。距离我们上次见面已经过去15多年了。哦，操，兄弟，最近怎么样？我们击拳相拥，他直接坐在了我旁边。嘿，你还在写吗？当伊万问我是否还在涂鸦时，我停顿了一下。因为事实是，什么都没有真正改变。我还在写。我只是不再在墙壁、巴士或高速公路上写了。但我依然在写
to be seen. Yeah, I told Ivan. I do still write. The lead producer for this episode is Elizabeth Nakano, supporting producer Tumiko Adams. Our editor is Arwin Nix, our senior producer is Megantan. Our sound engineer is Valentino Rivera, original music by Andrew Epe. This episode was written by me Walter Thompson Hernandez with help from Elizabeth Encano. Angela Bromstad is our executive producer. For more information on this episode of Scarrett Strait, go to l-a-s-t.com forward slash California Love. California Love is a production of Alaya Studios. I'm the host, Walter Thompson Hernandez.
为了被看见。是的，我告诉伊万。我确实还在写。本集的首席制作人是伊丽莎白·中野（Elizabeth Nakano），支持制作人为富美子·亚当斯（Tomiko Adams）。我们的剪辑师是阿温·尼克斯（Arwin Nix），高级制作人是梅根·坦（Megantan）。我们的音响工程师是瓦伦蒂诺·里维拉（Valentino Rivera），原创音乐由安德鲁·埃佩（Andrew Epe）创作。本集由我沃尔特·汤普森-埃尔南德斯（Walter Thompson Hernandez）在伊丽莎白·恩卡诺的协助下撰写。安吉拉·布隆姆斯坦（Angela Bromstad）是我们的执行制作人。有关“Scarrett Strait”本集的更多信息，请访问 l-a-s-t.com 斜杠 California Love。“California Love”是 Alaya Studios 的作品。我是主持人沃尔特·汤普森-埃尔南德斯。
Thanks for listening. I really appreciate you. This is just one of an eight-part series. I encourage you to subscribe to California Love so you can hear the more. We'll have a link in the show notes. 99% of visible is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colgstead, Sophia Klatsker, Katie Mangle, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sean Riel, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroube, Abbey Madon, and me Roman Morris. We are founding members of Radio Topia from PRX
感谢收听。我真的很感激你们。这只是八部分系列节目中的第一部分。我鼓励你订阅“California Love”以便收听更多内容。我们会在节目简介中提供链接。“99% Invisible”由德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、库尔特·科尔格斯特德（Kurt Colgstead）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、凯蒂·曼格尔（Katie Mangle）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、维维安·李（Vivian Leigh）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、阿比·马顿（Abby Madon）以及我罗曼·莫里斯（Roman Morris）共同制作。我们是来自 PRX 的 Radio Topia 的创始成员
and still based in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. You can not fret while the new episode from us next week. In the meantime, check out and pre-order our new book. It's called The 99% of Visible City at 99pi.org slash book. Or pick out and discover and share a cool story about design at cities in the built world and share it with your friends at 99pi.org. Radio topi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并且仍然总部设在美丽加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。下周我们将推出新节目，敬请期待。在此期间，请查看并预订我们的新书。它名为“The 99% of Visible City”，网址是 99pi.org 斜杠 book。或者在 99pi.org 上发现并分享关于城市和建筑世界设计的一个酷炫故事，并与你的朋友分享。radiotopia.org。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。